From the very opening scene of "The Batman,"
new villain the Riddler enacts a murderous
and effective campaign of terror to expose
the corruption at the heart of Gotham City.
The frightening villain first targets city
officials while leaving a series of riddles
chock-full of clues for Batman to uncover
the conspiracy that has turned Gotham rotten.
In fact, Riddler later tells an appalled Batman
that he was inspired by the Caped Crusader's
own use of violence in crafting his plans
to permanently change the city and its infrastructure.
The Riddler is eventually captured, but Batman
is too late to work out the final part of
his plan.
After the Riddler's car bombs destroy the
breakwaters of Gotham, flooding the downtown
area, his followers intend to kill mayor-elect
Bella Reàl and shoot into the crowd of people
taking refuge in the stadium.
Batman and Catwoman are forced to fight the
Riddler's devotees and save the city residents.
Fans praised how the early stages of the Riddler's
master plan felt but were very split over
his scheme in the last act.
Here's why.
In a discussion of "The Batman" in the r/movies
subreddit, some superhero fans were frustrated
by how nonsensical the Riddler's endgame is
compared to what one user called, quote, "[his]
(brilliant) plan to publicly embarrass, expose,
and assassinate the city's leadership" earlier
in the movie.
The Riddler did tell his devotees that he
wanted real change enacted in Gotham.
But creating a major disaster via bombing
Gotham's sea walls, and then using that flood
to kill mayor-elect Bella Reàl is not on
par with the string of killings Riddler masterminded
earlier in the movie.
The same redditor also noticed that the mayhem
didn't even make sense.
They wrote,
"The plan was to get everyone in the stadium
and have like 10 guys in masks snipe everyone?
Why not just blow up the building?"
The scheme seems like it'd be too easy for
someone like Batman to foil compared to the
destructive power of a bomb or another device.
It's understandable, then, that some fans
took issue with the Riddler expanding his
lethal crusade to ordinary citizens instead
of just corrupt city officials.
Part of the issue is that, unlike "Batman
Begins," which involves the villain tampering
with Gotham's water supply in the final act,
the destruction of Gotham's sea wall isn't
foreshadowed or telegraphed to the audience
at all.
One Reddit user noticed that, writing,
"...at no point in the movie are we ever told
about a sea wall keeping Gotham dry.
Suddenly ... [The Riddler is] blowing up dikes
to drown the city and wash everything away."
It's worth noting that there were some passing
references to the seawall - like hidden on
Riddler's floor map and in newspaper clippings,
so you would've had to pay attention to the
small details to figure out the clues.
The flooding also doesn't feel consistent
with the tone of the dark, stripped-down film.
Compared to the detective story at the heart
of "The Batman," the last 30 minutes are more
of the climax to what feels like a standard,
action-packed superhero blockbuster.
One Reddit user wrote that, in their opinion,
"the final act was needlessly dramatic compared
to the rest of the movie that felt pretty
grounded until that point."
However, other Redditors pointed out that
the final scenes help complete Batman's arc.
Throughout "The Batman," the titular hero
often comes off more like a movie monster
than a superhero.
Batman is obsessed with the "Gotham Project,"
and as Bella Reàl observes, isn't doing much
to help the population when he's Bruce Wayne.
"You really could be doing more for this city.
Your family has a history of philanthropy,
but near as I can tell, you're not doing anything."
But when Batman saves the innocent folks trapped
in the flooded downtown arena, this leads
Mayor Reál and the helpless citizens to trust
him enough to lead them out of the flood.
He also recognizes that the Riddler shooters
are traumatized, angry people, much like himself.
One Redditor argued that "seeing Batman evolve
as a hero through those scenes [was] crucial".
Additionally, Bruce empathizes with the people
he rescues as well as the shooters.
In the end, Batman decides that he can't only
personify "vengeance" but should also be an
inspiration to the residents of Gotham who
just survived a terrifying event.
Arguably, "The Batman" could have had a different
climax, but it might not have delivered the
same emotional payoff.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.